like i talked to my dad
on a podcast for four hours
and i'm not sure i wouldn't i would ever
talk to him
in the way we talked without the podcast
what does he do
uh physicist oh [ __ ] but like
yeah it's uh episode 100 and
you know
i uh the way i recorded that podcast is
i tried to put my ego aside it's
actually
really tough to talk to your dad
especially because you're giving him a
platform
uh especially so at that time there's
already a bit of a platform for this
podcast
and so there's this as a sun
you think like oh here it goes with this
[ __ ] again like that's the natural
sun
thought you have but at the same time i
wanted to
the way i thought about it is in 20
years when i look back like i want to do
a conversation where i'm
happy with it you know so i want to make
him shine
but i also called him out on like why
were you so distant
like like all that kind of stuff yeah it
was very difficult to do but it was
really important to do and i don't think
i'd be able to do it without a
without a microphone right listen how
often do we sit there and just focus our
attention just look at the other person
i i don't know man this is not even
recording right now
i just invited you over just so we could
actually you're right the podcast does
make like i listen
i've been listening to every word you've
been saying and if we weren't doing a
podcast
i might be looking at my phone or being
self-conscious about something else or
you're nervous or excited
zoomed in especially with people close
to you i mean that was i recommend that
actually for people
to talk to their family on a podcast
okay or like
fake or not that's really powerful uh
it made me realize that there's a clear
distinction between the conversations we
usually have with humans and those we
have
on the podcast is being recorded um
what the [ __ ] were we talking about
before that uh i i knew you were gonna
lose your train of thought on that one
because
that's a big one there's a motion behind
that one podcast with dad is gonna take
that's gonna take you to a place i took
you to a place it took you outside of
interviewer new york place yeah yeah in
new york and yang yeah
uh so the data one of the things that
really surprised me about
[Laughter]
i like the psychoanalysis you just threw
in there
yeah i took you that took you to a place
so uh angie yang
mentioned respect me now dad mit is that
enough
[ __ ] million people listening to this
14 rogans
is that enough dad i'm creating robots
is that enough for you
that's what drives you probably that's
probably what drives me that's what
gives meaning to life is it's never
enough
and i hope to pass that on to my kids
one day uh that nothing's ever enough
whether they're robot or human right
your kids most likely let's be honest
bro you might call one of your robots
if you love your road are you starting
to love your is it going to be like that
pygmalion thing you create them and then
they kill you but even while they're
killing you you've got to tear off the
tear
a slow one one tier one tier and just
yeah why are you doing this frankenstein
why why but i loved you those would be
the last words out of my mouth
you